okay four people joining this live
stream we are in the process of
finishing some pieces of version 12 of
language and we are tidying up loose
ends and so on and this one has to do
with cryptography we've introduced some
new cryptography functionality for
blockchain operations and we are trying
to make sure it's properly integrated
okay so this is our traditional public
key crypto stuff okay you know I have to
say that this shortening thing is not
the most beautiful we should one day try
and do something about that that looks a
bit you could strobe right there instead
oh no no no no shoulder at all because I
think Stephen is more talking about like
maybe it dot dr. lips or something yes a
long number but yeah maybe don't show
them at all because they don't make
sense here you know you don't see them
and they don't go on I mean you are
effectively seeing a hash of them by
seeing the first few digits on the last
few digits so to know whether they are
the same as something else is useful so
I don't just I don't think you know to
see that that's the same as this is
useful I usually add a picture
what is the icon the icon is the icon is
a representation of the key so if there
comes the same then the key is the same
yes I know but you can see that the
public key is the same in this case the
private key is missing from the public
key great yeah right so I think it is
useful I'm merely commenting on the the
angle bracket thing what's the decision
like have a dot dot or are you okay with
the sixteen there are it's okay it's
look I think in general we should review
whether short should have can we put it
on the aisle the agenda to review what
the visual appearance of short is yeah
that's an action item yes the appearance
of short ok indeed of integers yes okay
let's look at elliptic curves okay so
this is now new
you want to have type they're an
elliptic curve with the name of the
specific elliptic curve in parentheses
okay call on our live stream is
supporting the short should look nicer
in the front end good okay so now this
is okay
assuring that and yep this looks good if
you open it up then there's d grads
multiplier and public court went we
trained teachers well that interests but
disappointingly unshown but is it a
single integer there it's where of
integers why does it say I'd go back at
one then again it's like you're on so
short yeah same issue it's one line the
short short is have one line you know
yeah I know I know what it's doing but I
don't think short did that in the case
of if I just do you know 100 factorial
200 factorial and then I say short of
that I'm surprised if it generates um oh
wow well that's just a bug is the way
you know the number of line it's the
number of lines not the number of lines
it's not uh node it's simply not it was
no it's not I wrote this code back in
like nineteen eighty eighty seven or
something no are you saying argument
count yes it should be what it should be
the argument count maybe it should be to
those things like this well there should
be one no it should be the argument
count if I say short of range of a
thousand ten thousand or something
see it's the number of omitted arguments
and the number of omitted arguments in
this case is two because nothing is
showing right it's a bug of some kind
so in idea another idea that to show
short of integer for this T case he you
is to use a picture again like spotting
sparkline or maybe at this icon type so
you can't write about this right now
it's not it would be nice to get this
right but I think it will be gotten
right when short is improved okay let's
not solve that problem for this okay
okay so let's keep going this looks good
you know the message is basically the
text at you you're using row keys yeah
that's the message you want it you may
want to support elliptic Keys later but
we need to this to get what kind of
algorithm so they're available for lip
to curve I'm just thinking about the
wording of this um okay it's alright
okay scroll down there is a table call
our live stream is rightly asking why
isn't this method error to curve yes you
can use that this is a shorthand for
that you can can't you can say method
are elliptic curve yeah does the same
thing it was just a shorthand for that
um okay so let's keep going here for
some properties are in the key and some
properties are computed on the fly okay
all right so if I if I look at one of
these if I say input form okay so is it
true
repeat them so public byte array is a
repeat for public curved pointers that
correct is yeah okay
do we care that to repeat or do E's
argument is a repeating data is not a
good usually is not a good thing but it
doesn't take much space so it's pretty
small and it it's so commonly used that
we don't want to make it you know
I want to turn ideas on the fly so you
might have saw just computed once and
have it there okay did we agree that
compressed was gonna be the name for
that by the way what's a single other I
assume Doria is here yes okay and that's
the way it's method everywhere okay okay
okay okay
so these these links are united
variables but you didn't say your
preference in it so we just chose
quantity okay it's not what's been done
for RSA as well if I say in this case
here um let's see and now I say that now
what would I what will be I'd be asking
ridiculous
it has there been implemented yet
because that's not what the heck is that
what is that yeah that's about the
bugging quality so we have to screenshot
okay but that's in bits anyway it's a
unit of quantity so you're doing the
right thing
good yeah it was forever say to do the
same thing this very precursor in the
quantity okay all right okay bye it's
frozen be not as white it in bits n bits
I mean bits shoulders be you're probably
okay but that's not the listening to
discuss I mean looks weird to me but
it's fine
um question I mean I look are you saying
that even an 11-3 that the private key
length for RSA was given so if I say
generate symmetric key I'll get the same
I just don't know I'm assuming that
you're just copying what was already
done is that correct no we didn't
connected this it was the same way
what's that called what's that element
called private key links no for a
symmetric key just you wait that's not
implemented yet if we're gonna do that
we have to left out that that's just
just King it makes sense to do it but
it's not that I know in this point I
have to say I think we should just use
integers because I think for these
cryptographic things you know it's
always bits
I think it's pedantic to say bits
because it's not going to be big enough
we're not gonna have a megabyte of key
last words mmm I disagree with that okay
because so the you can use it in two
different ways you can use in
mathematics in mathematics all right
right so much called written like prime
prime number composition then using you
need integers however for practical
users everywhere people here for as byte
sequences objects no no I'm asking a
different thing I'm simply asking should
we return the key length as an integer
or as a quantity
at all I'm asking oh yeah thanks I think
we should probably return it as an
integer yes because it's always it's
always it's always in bets um so let's
let's change that and here we should
support key lengths as well as a
property for symmetric key yeah Karl
here on our live stream is saying US
prefers united quantities and he would
wish his absolute timing returned
quantitate seconds I completely agree it
would he be even better if we had a time
machine so we could go back and fix that
from one absolute timing with first
introduced but yes um but I don't think
in this case I don't think I don't think
you're gonna be wanting to combine these
bit lengths with other things that's why
I'm thinking that they should just be
integers but I might be wrong
um how that can be used and then yeah I
know well my idea was it like what I
understood from your wish is that public
key lengths is supposed to be used as a
you know information to yourself how
long it is this information to yourself
it's finalized clarity if you were a
disapprobation is it well we can I mean
integers gonna be convenient yeah I mean
like for example if you say I wonder
what happens if I take that quantity in
bits and I say to ^ that what on earth
do I get well you get some kind of
stupid bug right now but but notice that
that doesn't for example but what kind
of Union troops do you expect I don't
really know I mean I'm expecting a
combinatorial thing but okay mmm
let's loop back to this I'm not sure
what to do somebody is asking on the
live stream whether there is new
capability for working with Bart trains
and I'm happy to report that there is a
lot of new capability for working with
block chains lots of wonderful things
here um very sophisticated stuff for
doing generating addresses signing
validating messages it's all there in
fact we use the selected curve stuff
specifically for that right this is how
what is this this is a blockchain
transaction sign what is that
transaction that you are the one who
ascended this transaction and so on but
where did you get that key from is that
generated from was that generated using
generate no how is that key generated I
didn't know we do work in this block
chain pages yeah I ask Christian to join
but he had an appointment so he's gonna
be real light if you want to discuss
blockchain
okay oh look at that I'm not sure I've
seen this where it says fee is this what
we agreed that just the word fee is in
red that's also probably a question for
Christian no I mean what that means is
if you if you submit this thing to the
blockchain you are spending 7,000
Satoshi and that's an attempt to tell
you that um better not put that in the
automated just weaken yes that's right
I'm gonna get a big bill at the end of
the year all right well although on the
test net that what what happened I don't
quite understand on the test net why is
that fee in red after the test net well
I don't know um that's just bad it's
like a virtual good that that's not an
actual feat in right in the case of the
test net that is correct
okay let's continue here okay ref pages
these would have been nice as links so
do you think you've you've got these
rough pages all straightened out
no not yet I just have enough time yet
we had two meetings okay okay
I mean I'm mostly just learning from da
really
but this is what I already wrote right I
did this last time yeah but I think
there was a another table we need to
address the type is similar to birds and
with my dead properties if you call it
key size it's not us it has been there
okay you know what what are you guys
telling me this is already I asked you
was this already done and the answer is
yes it's already been done so please
don't change it um I don't think this
was changed right there yeah okay so in
that case please don't use units because
we didn't use it already and there's key
size and then what is this generate a
symmetric target size of key in bits so
which key is that it's a noisy key okay
but in the case of in the case of of
elliptic curves is there not is there no
longer a single number there are two
numbers that we have to give now in case
of elliptic curve you cannot specify a
key size because it's defined by the
field of would be curved table for RSA
which is no no I understand that but we
want a compatible thing what it what is
the thing what is the access or that you
are providing for elliptic curves this
says no no growl look this is called key
size for some rules our reason this is
called key length we got to have it be
consistent right here
okay so generate if we look at generates
symmetric key I bet that that has a key
size right automatic size of key in bits
okay we just need to change that then -
couple of key size as an integer well
hold on hold on when this says key size
for RSA what does that key size refer to
the private key or the public key
Daria and I am not sure again it
remembers okay I think it's both okay
because they're the same size yes
they're both they're the same size is
that obvious that they're the same size
I don't even serve this all right so
what we probably should do and again it
will be good - Daria can you check into
this I mean it probably what we're gonna
do what to say if we introduce so if we
call it length then it's definitely not
going to be units right it's definitely
not going to be unity - it's called
length it's going to be um you know a
number if it's size it could be unity
but we didn't unit it before so I think
what we should do hmm I'm wondering
whether we should introduce key length
as an alternative to key size and then
call it private key length public key
lengths then for RSA we're going to have
to also support private key length
public key length but they're both set
to the same thing as key lengths but
police might be different in a few bits
No so one maybe two four seven and then
maybe for 100 for eight okay so it's
coincidental they were the same in this
particular case yes is that right okay
well then then this is wrong that we've
had that we have private that then them
okay my place yeah go ahead
key size on killings sound I don't I
don't see the difference so we can just
keep reading
he's killing psyche science and the
difference is this if it's called key
length then that is going to be an
integer nobody is going to be confused
by that being an integer if we say key
size arguably that should be a unit of
quantity in bytes or in bits or whatever
see what I'm saying I don't know yeah
why will they expect unions but we have
to keep key size the same for backward
compatibility we do but we could retire
key size and rename it key length I
don't know there may have been a good
reason when I was called key size
originally I mean Christopher would
probably know that some key size is the
same thing as as what as the public
modulus length or something else I don't
know the answer to that yes miss you
believe in discussions it is actually
public modulus because private can be a
few bits smaller for some reason okay
then I think what we should do is what I
think we should say um we should make it
be public key like that somebody's
typing in that ear by the way public key
length private key length and in the
case of symmetric key we should have
something where we can where we call it
where we rename it key lengths although
we continue to support key size that all
of these things are pure integers
okay and in the case of we continue to
support key size here but we I mean but
we document it and we instead document
public key length private key lengths
make sense
dharia on owed Constantine and did you
get that as a as an action item or do I
need to write it
no I got it so we keep key size that we
undocumented to those tilts to work and
then key length will be an integer
yes it will be good to send one email to
Christopher and asked him whether he had
a profound reason for choosing key size
rather than key link for the name of
this this field analyst and then what
does it relate to in the actual keys
that we have I mean it does it relate to
the public modulus link I don't know
that's a question about RSA that I don't
know the answer to and hopefully Daria
can figure that out yeah I will check
the code but it seems like it's a public
right or ask Christopher who might or
might not remember that level of detail
about this um okay but my feeling is
this if I could say that the
it's nice to have a correspondence
between what you know what you see in
the summary blog the summary bucks you
know like when it's called public
largest length in the summary oh heck I
met Mel yes imagine about me right I
agree with the names I sold it if the
names are so different you don't really
know you never know I agree with you
that's wrong when it says public modulus
like that should just say public key
links private key links
so that's exactly right and I summary
blood
this but is a modulus the same thing as
a key
not sure if that's true I think it is
these are all parameters right if I
receive public key consists of two
things which is modulus and the public
expand which is the last thing on the
blog so like is a public key is compound
oh I see oh boy okay that may be why
it's called size rather than length
because we're trying to avoid the
confusion about digit length
okay so in this case in the case of
of elliptic curve oh boy
okay so I'm beginning to come back to
wanting to call this public key size
unless it's a length in bits is it a
length in bits of this number in this
particular case but what if but then
this compressed versus non compressed
thing is it really the key length or is
it the length of each individual
coordinate in the public curve point
you
is a size of a typical like 507 is one
Korean plus second third you need
permit the public length has both the
coordinates in it has is representing
both of those together
okay I'm sorry I'm changing my mind
again this should be public key sighs to
avoid the confusion of the length of the
digits right because otherwise yeah it
should be sighs that was the right
public key five private willoughby lies
in bits or bytes or but I think we
already crossed that bridge I think it
has to be an integer and then the
ancient er integer represents what
exactly what it is right now it's it is
if you look at the hex string if you
look at the byte array it is a number of
base 2 bits to represent that 12 per
trillion 903 yeah yeah it's much bigger
than trillion then um
oh boy is it gonna crash
no okay that's what it is um maybe we
should just represent it like that
like this I think that's a bad idea um
okay okay so public key size an integer
and we leave everything that we talked
about before okay but it still five
outset it's 507 yes okay it still be
exact
it's the smallest number of bits you
need exactly representing them
okay generate symmetric key should be
exactly the same there should be no
change needed to this okay by the way do
you support this business about
passwords and byte arrays for generate a
symmetric key pair can you give it a
password oh no you're giving it a type
here
because in this case notice that
symmetric keys so Daria question there's
no seeding of the asymmetric key is that
right you just takes all of us yeah and
the reason for that is that it's like
you've got to find a prime and things
it's not like you get to in this case
with the symmetric key it's kind of like
anything can be ground up to make a
symmetric key it is possible to support
that password for an generators maybe
with you guys Oh jr. a symmetric key the
users password in the sense how quick or
proceed so if you give the same password
you get the same key but if you don't
give the password then it draws
randomness from system random generator
and a symmetric key for RSA does the
same so without the password it just
grows randomness but if you give
password then yeah what's wrong
using a key derivation function from the
password but I don't think you can use
that I think that a symmetric key is a
sparse whereas symmetric keys are dense
a symmetric keys are sparse but maybe
that's not true of all methods a browser
I said and now about elliptic curve a
symmetric key can be any number from 1
to basically the size of filled almost
so we can try to for randomness with the
password so it's sort of password this
would say she'd and for our forest of
which it occurs you could probably the
same idea just okay but look at the
syntax here because generate is
symmetric key you're just feeding that
string in and right now for generate a
symmetric key is putting in things like
elliptic curve here for a symmetric key
you use the random but you don't you
don't see the password because I found
you actually haven't seen that anybody
will do that
no I don't know a use case although it
is interesting so Daria if you do that
Phaedo accede to the elliptic curve for
generating a symmetric key pair what are
you going to get are you going to get
something how does it reflect the seed
we could use the process as we seed like
a random integer and other functions oh
I see what you're saying we could seed
the randomness oh wow
you don't use yes or what we could do we
could take a bus for then do some like
things like H Mac or something like that
out of it yeah that's what it's doing
here can you feed an H Mac output into
the elliptical you're saying you can
pick any point on the elliptic curve
well you can put any multiplier which is
yeah pretty a big range things so you
can try to make an HVAC and then convert
it to integer and then that would be a
product multiplier
yeah okay but one thing this is this
leads me to is the fact that there
probably should be a random seating
option in these functions I mean it's
kind of weird it's kind of crazy so the
thing is really seeing does not apply to
a system randomness if you want
cryptography strong keys then you don't
use you know then you're crazy right I
mean if you say random seeding arrow one
two three four you will always get the
same I mean the advantage of doing that
is that for testing and so on you will
always get the same asymmetric key pair
yes yes I think that would be useful but
you would not use it for if you know you
be crazy totally bonkers
I mean well to be more accurate if you
thought you had a high entropy source of
randomness and you didn't trust the high
entropy
so sir animus on your computer then you
could then you could use this so let's
investigate introducing random seating
here then you should use you should also
add random cheating in generate
symmetric key absolutely okay another
thing forgetting the same table time is
what we're playing to do is what we're
having assigned by this private key in
whatever form just to generate a public
one out of it that will give you the
same public key every time is what is if
you give a private key yeah so we plan
to I mean it's only the kind in the code
but we plan to make it better and
improve it and expose it given your
private key as an integer or a string or
whatever generate the public key no no
not as an integer or a string as a as a
private key blob I would say technically
it's not gonna work right because what
you've got to do okay so let me walk
walk me through this because what you're
saying is if I say public key of private
key blah blah blah that's supposed to
work is that right no it's just I'm
saying for the future instead of posting
receipt we should just make a separate
function for generating a public key
well why is it a separate function which
is a public key or private key that
would then generate a public key from
the private key I mean you have enough
information and the private key symbolic
object to do this is that correct yes
okay I think that would be nice I mean
it would also be useful for people
understanding what the heck's going on
to see that that's possible um for this
version of um none of this the random
seeding thing on this is definitely not
for this version okay I mean for this
version we are hopefully at the end here
um by the way Carl on the live stream is
asking whether he can feed an image to
Jenna
symmetric-key what's the answer as a
password slow notice that here we say
quotes possible but generate derived key
what does generate derive key does it
allow an image it allows both arrays it
allows just lists so you can feed an
image represented as no no I don't want
to do that what Wieck why doesn't it
just allow me to feed an arbitrary
random piece of junk here because there
are different ways to interpret that and
I should not assume which way you want
because I can stretch this image in a
stream of bits and use that or I can do
it why don't we have a canonical way to
do it there is no this way ok so the
main point is that you generate derived
key ok hold on let me understand why
don't you just use hash of image and
then feed it to drive key that'll work
it's a canonical way do we document
right to put that in the documentation
it's a reasonable way to do it yeah if
we hash the owl although we need to you
know we'll get in trouble with the hour
I'm not take an integer it will take us
drink string yeah so in your thoughts
you specify what kind of output for hush
that seems bit messy ok this is a
separate question why does generate
derive key not take an expression for
this reason because there is no
communica way to toll expression into
whatever we want it so it will be quite
random quite arbitrary choice we had
this issue with encrypt as well but
encrypts it and doing this right and
encrypt your file as long as you can
decrypt so when I hear a derived key
actually I agree because the input for
derive or generate key the the first
argument is your password so if the
image is your password you should be
able to use the image to verify it
yeah well so what happens if I use a the
the owl to encrypt the owl does that
work no okay I there must have been a
good reason for this I mean this was
extensively debated when we were
building encrypt originally you can
raise the question Christopher would
remember what the issue was with this
why don't you ask him but for now we
don't let's not worry about it generate
using an image for a skier that's thing
about something I don't think it's any
more possible than it is to use it for
the password for encrypt that they're
the same thing
okay let's keep going down here
okay so encrypt the only thing we're
doing here is that it doesn't work with
with elliptic curves right otherwise
everything's the same we didn't change
ok generate digital signature did we
change something in generate digital
signature good well I know that I am
aware but I mean is there something that
we have to change now I meant change it
relative to last week or whatever with
respect to the documentation no it
really just I rewrote it all the
examples and I confirmed the deal work
with the new changes ok so we put in
hashing method all that kind of thing
signature type you know this we already
did this documentation before ok good ok
encrypted object nothing changed an
encrypted object correct because you did
you don't have any new forms of
encryption you basically I just need
says because there is a property
properties about yeah what are those
properties properties optionally
properties property which gives you a
list of properties
it's for all for all objects and I think
I mentioned last time but I would I
don't think it's essential right now
it's all of the others so we agree on
that
well okay fine but then then put it in
this table list of available properties
properties quotes properties list of
available properties okay I'll do it for
this case I think usually it's done
separately but is it yeah because it's a
meta thing right it's like the thing
that lists all the it's a little bit
okay okay okay whatever you want to do
I'm a green it off the top of my head I
think it fits
that's how yes I look so another point
just that's all right okay okay um okay
Brian on the live stream is asking will
the new crypto functions support the
same algorithms as the major operating
systems yeah the answer is yes I believe
and and I believe they're all
interoperable and they'll make heaven
files and all kinds of things like this
um they also coming later is interaction
with the system keychain that's coming
in 12:00 1:00 you know in fact so both
direct key and fresh and encryption we
ratify against unknown test vectors so
it generates the same data right part of
the test sheet are all fips-compliant
algorithms supported does anybody know
the answer to that no wait the chips
compliance link is the so analytical for
example but there are like a dozen of
them a dozen flips compliant elliptic
curves yeah what is it what is involved
in getting um what's involved in in
supporting other elliptic curves I just
need more time to you know test the
focus functions can actually work with
them because dependent occurs are just
the sake of you know different set of
field and different generating
generation of group so they might work
easy they didn't have time to do really
okay fine so it's a matter of way to
represent the curve and then
generalizing algorithms that we have to
accept and it is a call separate thing
about mathematically supporting elliptic
curve operations and and I believe
Christopher wrote a package ages ago to
do that other than anybody's looked at
that yes and this thing that isn't
[ __ ] now gives the same result okay
right but it but it's the but the point
of that was to expose the mathematical
things like multiplying points in order
to curves and so on but I don't know
whether we need to do that but I think
that's a whole separate issue it's a
good idea maybe we should start off just
putting it in the function repository um
okay just a quick look ahead at these
things
oh okay so call on the live stream is
asking about importing pem files yes it
should import as a private key public
key pair right is that does that work
right now it doesn't it won't be in the
next release of them okay okay so we're
not supporting it at all they're not
well it's an image okay but it but what
will happen is you say import of the
thing that will give you that same
Association that
generate a smell yes okay nice um okay I
thought we already had H Mac generate
isn't that what generate derived key is
doing no no it's a different thing
generosity they could the whole point is
that it is slow must be slow and the
other functions they must be fast so
it's not good but I thought H Mac was
intended to be slow it's no it's bits
per person it's different okay
encode encode is a mess
oh yeah so I spoke to one of the users
and she wants to encrypt the package and
then on another computer to be able to
what we really need to do is to that
that's part of the code obfuscation you
know code encryption stuff which we need
to I guess this group should probably
take that on I mean that was a whole
discussion about code actually so it was
mentioned to me several times I just
need some official go for this so I can
work but there's more to this there's
the whole DRM thing let's separate meet
it okay to discuss how to do this and
then we get to test whether it's
security by obscurity by whether we
think we can live stream that meeting um
the okay let's see let's see
Carlin live stream is asking about
exporting to to PEM files yes so that's
part of the plan is to be able to export
a private key public key pair that's
what points for like that that's one
point for in this list o import and
export of m-files okay Brian on the live
stream is asking about Windows dot CER
files it's the same same thing yes it's
different format okay but so that's also
part of the plan yeah
okay compressing and decompressing
elliptic curve public keys that is
already implemented but not you know
it's good to be exposed really because
it's what it's doing inside the code
well I don't even know what this means
is this that's good press true and false
is I right yeah going from one form to
the other by converting from one form to
another why does one care and different
implementations of some grantees might
use both well but then what we should do
is to have a property that you can
extract that it's called compressed
public key you know public curved point
and and uncompressed public curved point
we don't need a separate function I mean
that's just a that's just an access or
mcerf point is always uncompressed
compressed is gives just one coordinate
okay fine well so just have a different
access or for the for the keys that give
you the the single coordinate was what I
would think about doing that makes sense
mm-hmm okay
um do we really need more hashing
algorithms you said that so low priority
it'll be okay I mean I would also like
to point out that I would like to see it
in in the symmetric key thing in
encryption I would like to see some
classic encryption schemes yes but it's
not it doesn't belong to her she doesn't
belong to encrypt it does belong to
encrypt a Caesar cipher is happily
belongs to encrypt you say generate
symmetric key for a Caesar cipher and
it's not very secure exactly but then
you feed that key in to encrypt and it
will encrypt by using a Caesar cipher
well it's a different type of key and it
actually does not quite fit to the
function so I mean why is it a different
type of key why substitution key no it's
it look look the question know with
respect to this method you know cipher
arrow Caesar
and then it's got all kinds of random
junk here that says you know right I
would think it's just a different choice
of of I mean for these methods it so
happens that the same things are
supported here but an initialization
vectors and so on are supported but I
think for these other ones like enigma
for example I mean I'm sure enigma has I
think enigma has an analogue when
initialization vector doesn't it right
so I mean in fact an enigma is really no
different is it from like a random AES
cipher or something it's just a simpler
version of it isn't it
or am I wrong well simply as just
substitute a lot of things I asked does
it gradually this is just you know
basically randomizing stuff right okay
well anyway I mean I thought we had
summer school projects and things where
people that implemented stuff like this
and I'm surprised we can't just plug it
in well maybe it's something for Daria
to look at at some point um don't spend
too much time on it but it would be a
nice thing to have I think all right
sounds good I think we're we are in good
shape here um lots of stuff to look
forward to for the next version
hopefully this is not too time-consuming
but these are super useful and certainly
the PEM file thing is really needed okay
um and I would put that as the highest
priority of this of the stuff I think
general elliptic curve support would be
nice but um I think the PEM file thing
is really important we need that for a
bunch of you know cloud computing stuff
and so on okay um and then we want to
see the documentation one more time and
I think there's a few more things I need
to be tweaked
especially the - tree just some email
when you have it ready I'll take a look
um I'll send your screenshots yeah
sounds good okay good work thanks a lot
everybody
thank you for folks on the livestream a
lot of useful comments they're much
appreciated
all right see you later